My pancreatic system started at 3.5 and the second test was 4.2, just did another
ultrasound of a 3.2. I'm waiting on my RGCC to come back. Any chance my cancer
markers could be increasing while the system is decreasing? Or is that not enough
to have a decrease to make a big deal of? Well, I'd say, I mean, I mean that's
25% decrease, 4.2 to 3.2. That's a big decrease. So I think that's great. Will you
have a change in your tumor markers? You may. I mean, again, you've seen, you've
heard from other people that tumor markers can be fickle. So a person can go on
chemo that's actually shrinking the tumor and the tumor workers actually go on
because the cancer cells can spill more of that protein. So you have to look
at multiple markers when you look at whether or success or failure. So look at
your symptoms, look at how everything else is going. Look at tumor markers. I
think it's a good thing to measure on a regular basis so you can get, you know,
graph that out and see the trend. So that's what you want to look for.